in this video i'm going to show you how
to make an old film effect in after
effects that will give your videos an
old-school vintage look
hey everyone my name is cameron with
motion science and in this video i'm
going to show you how to create an old
film effect in after effects this is a
really simple process and it's a great
way to give your videos that vintage
look so this process will work with any
footage and what i have here is an old
school film projector the first thing i
want to do is give it that old school
vintage shake up and down so i'm going
to select p for position
right click separate dimensions and on
the y position i'm going to control or
alt click to add an expression and i'm
going to type in wiggle
parentheses 24 so 24 times per second i
want the y position to fluctuate by 6
pixels i'm going to click enter on my
keyboard and you can see we've already
got this really interesting vertical
shake happening next thing we're going
to do is add a new adjustment layer and
we're going to call this effects to this
adjustment layer i'm going to go to
effect color correction
curves and i'm going to add
one
two
three points i'm gonna bring up my
shadows
i'm gonna bring down my highlights so
you have a curve that looks something
like this doesn't have to be perfect
next i'm going to add effect color
correction
hue and saturation
and i'm going to drop my saturation by
about 25.
next i'm going to add an effect blur and
sharpen camera lens blur and i'm going
to alter option click on blur radius
i'm going to type in wiggle parentheses
6 comma
10 so 6 times per second i have a
frequency of 10 i want to add in
some blur like we see here
next i'm going to do is add an effect
color correction exposure
and i am going to change this from
master individual channels go to the
blue channel blue exposure alter option
click add another expression wiggle
parentheses 24 times per second at a
value of 0.5 i want the exposure
to adjust you can see here the look is
really starting to come together next
effect we're going to add is under
effect
stylize
cc vignette and we're going to create a
pretty high amount of vignetting
200 for an alter option click there
wiggle parentheses 6 comma 100 so 6
times per second
at a value of 100 we are going to create
a vignette that pushes in and out
on our subject matter we're getting
closer next i'm going to bring in some
grain from the film textures pack from
motion science you can also add your own
grain in the effects within after
effects i'm going to use this grain from
the texture pack drop the scale down to
50 percent since it is a 4k file set the
transfer mode to screen
and now we've got some really nice grain
over the top as you can see there
looking awesome next i'm going to add
another new adjustment layer
and we'll call this time
and to the time layer we're going to go
to effect
time
posterize time and we're going to change
the frame rate from 24
down to 18
and by adding the posterize time effect
we're bringing the
frames per second down to that old
school
vintage film frame rate at this point
you could call it good or you can take
it even one step further by adding two
more layers to this composition to do
that i'm going to use a film burn
from the motion science film textures
pack i'm going to drop that in below the
effects here
and i'm going to set this to screen mode
and just kind of take a look you can see
what it looks like here if i go ahead
and solo this layer
[Music]
just a really subtle
film burn gives a little bit of extra
color to our composition as we can see
there and i'm also going to add some
film textures dirt from the motion
science texture pack we're going to go
with dirt
4
drop this below here scale it down to
about 75 again these are 4k files set
this to
screen and if i solo this you can see
here is the dirt texture i want to go
ahead and bring down the color of this
when i go to color correction
hue and saturation
and i'm going to drop this down to about
negative 50. so it's a little less color
in there we're going to go ahead and
unsolo this and check it out and there
we go there is our old school vintage
film look i hope that you've really
enjoyed this lesson on creating an old
school vintage film look please let me
know if you have any questions in the
comments i'd love to answer them for you
hit that like button if you enjoyed this
video and please subscribe to this
channel it helps other people find this
channel as well if you're looking to
upgrade your design skill set master the
art of style and execute like a pro i
have a course called stylecraft that you
can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description
thanks for watching i'm cameron and this
is motion science
[Music]
bye
[Music]